anonyme hommes d'église ou membres de la
famille royale
100 portraits sont mises en avant dans
cette exposition du musée long been et à
versailles il s'agit de prêts privés des
oeuvres réunies pendant 30 ans par un
collectionneur français qui souhaite
garder l'anonymat
le choix a été fait par les allemands
qui est conservateur au louvre directeur
du département des arts graphiques et
qui a rencontré donc ce collectionneur
ya de nombreuses années le choix qui a
été fait par les abbés salma s'est porté
sur des portraits sur lesquels ils
étaient d'accord en termes d'attribution
une identification derrière chaque
tableau une histoire le point commun
entre ces visages ils ont tous vécu
durant le siècle des lumières les règnes
de louis xiv et louis saez y sont
représentés
l'exposition est organisée selon trois
grands thèmes la cour la ville et les
villes de province on montre que le
portrait évidemment est très représentée
à la cour pour défier l'image du roi la
famille royale et le xviiie siècle est
le siècle du portrait est aussi le
moment où on fait les nobles et les
bourgeois demande de plus en plus peut
aussi à se faire représenter une
rencontre avec son personnage aux
présentes hâtive du xviiie siècle
possible jusqu'au 1er mars
en parallèle des conférences et des
pièces de théâtre sont proposés au
public
[Musique]